head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
ladies and gentlemen last night's
Republicans won and then I wake up in
the morning and all the conservatives
are angry they're saying that uh this
was a an unusable election and we did so
poorly and I'm seeing all these leftist
personalities cheering and screaming
like oh no red wave and I'm just like I
don't understand the Republicans won
like they won that they they won and
there's likely more winning coming I get
it Republicans wanted a bloodbath but
instead they got a victory so now this
is great Biden says he won't change
anything after a successful night for
Dems does intend to run in 2024 and it
will be fun watching Don V Ron taunts
press okay he's not going to change
anything that's not the message that
people wanted to hear the message that
people want to hear is things are going
to get better but things are bad and for
a variety of reasons people are willing
to vote Democrat and a variety of really
weird reasons like they voted in the
dead guy but uh I don't think people
wanna uh I think I think I think people
used to be engaged in politics because
they want to get a glimpse of a better
world but that's the that's the uh
washing powder uh version of politics I
think people are well into bitterness I
think people want to see the bad guys
bleed I I think that people want to see
the the bloodbath that you're talking
about right right comes not from a
desire to reimagine the world in a
better way because I think people are
losing hope in that I think people want
to see their antagonists suffer I agree
um I agree and the reason for the
Republican uh frustration is that they
were expecting a rare moment of
catharsis which is not granted often to
people with um right of central politics
a moment in which they could reassure
themselves that sometimes Justice is
done that the universe is capable of
delivering
um uh
True Justice where it is where it is
warranted and they were robbed of that
so they were it's what was stolen from
them was not
um some kind of uh uh you know uh
washing powder commercial glimpse of a
better future what was stolen from them
was Revenge because these people don't
feel like they've been out of power and
that's a shame they feel like
um there are I mean they they articulate
their feelings now in very religious
terms uh and and they they talk about
their enemies in terms of demons devils
and Satan and the way in which they
express themselves
um you know and and the the uh the I
think the emotional the sunk emotional
costs that they had attached to the
midterms as a moment when they could
reassure themselves that maybe there was
um you know uh maybe there was still
some glimmer of but they won
well not really but they won what they
needed the house no they they uh what
what could they have done better what
would it was it was a bog standard or
slightly unimpressive midterm in which
the usual swing occurred that is not
what Republicans were expecting right
right they were not what they were
hoping for that's not a victory
um when when something happens that
always happens that happens whether you
campaign or not that happens whether you
do anything or not that's not a victory
that's um that's this people perceive
that as a kind of
um as a sort of a um
almost like a weather event you know
it's just part of the natural cycle of
things there was no Victory because
there was nothing above and beyond what
what um the ordinary course of a midterm
election I understand what you're saying
that they needed something that proved
something symbolic and something they
just they just wanted the people who
they feel are tearing their the fabric
of their civilization apart
um
uh doing all kinds of things that will
talk about in the uh no to to to suffer
they wanted to see their they wanted to
see the the
um I forget what the Conan quote is I
haven't seen it for 25 years but
um you know they wanted that
whatever the first time the Lamentations
were there women they wanted shrieking
they wanted the 2016 right right right
right they wanted let's see liberals
panic but that's that's nebulous in the
sense that by taking it no no no no
fundamental by winning the house there
can now be inquiries investigation
nobody cares about winning the house
right right so so listen everybody cares
about winning the house so why
Republican base is now
elections are here retribution for them
to feel the satisfaction is simply their
choice they got what they could get now
I suppose they wanted to see a
tremendous Landslide Victory which
wouldn't have changed anything
procedurally it would have felt good no
well I would just say I didn't they
didn't get what they could get they were
they rightly into hear it that they were
robbed of this Victory by people who
should have had their backs but what's
the victory what does Victory look like
they wanted to see their own enemies
humiliated right right and and they did
and the only and they're not being
humiliated is because Republicans are
acting like they lost no no no
um what happened in this election was um
not only were the leaders in the
Republican Party removing spending from
some of the most inspirational and
popular candidates which itself is a
form of demoralization
um and sabotaging
some of the candidates that had the most
promise for upsets those little things
that give you a burst of mass and a
burst of joy in an otherwise uh um yeah
um
yeah I mean you know
he would have been it would have been
nice if he'd won but
the what they correctly intuited is that
this was another example of the Republic
of powers that be in the Republican
Party leaving money on the table uh
actively sabotaging the candidates that
the base likes most because they hate
them and they are right about that
that's what happened
um the the powers that be in the
Republican Party sabotage some of the
candidates some of the candidates that
were the most popular with the base and
changed the result of some of those
elections uh through removing millions
of dollars in spending so the the
Republicans are acting out not because
they're um babies who are choosing to be
losers they're acting out because they
were wronged and they know it sure sure
but I don't think that that uh explains
Ben Shapiro for instance nothing
explains Ben Shapiro well look you look
at the daily wire guys and they're upset
about the results they're saying you
know uh to elect who has never had a
moment of contentment in their lives um
so perhaps that's it they weren't going
to be satisfied no matter what happened
well they weren't
[Laughter]
they won't be happy until a quite
different flag is flying over the White
House yeah but the midterm elections are
usually a referendum on the president's
term I think there's a reason why Biden
is coming out right now I'm going to be
I'm going to keep doing what I usually
do but they they historically
politically are and if we look at
previous midterms like in 2010 and 2014
the Republicans overwhelmingly won by
huge numbers they didn't do that at this
time the Senate again it is still
undecided these results don't match how
people feel about Biden they don't now
there are candidates
um that
are weird special cases like fetterman
who has inspired sympathy and he's he's
just I kind of I can't sort of like the
guy
um it just brings out you know kind of a
warm feeling I just kind of want to see
him succeed because I see him struggling
and I see a fetterman
normal response to seeing somebody
um struggling is to want to help them
you know like I watched that debate and
I I wanted to vote for the guy
um that what people are seeing is
results that are out of step with how
they know people feel about this
presidency and the reason those results
are out of step is the Republican
leadership do you think who who took who
didn't just sit by and say uh let's just
let what happens happen they actively
sabotaged the chances of some of the
most popular populist nationalists Trump
adjacent characters
um it is and and you know voters are a
little bit better informed and a little
bit um more intelligent I think than the
Washington people give them credit for
um they have correctly in intuited
betrayal they are not upset because the
results were you know they didn't get
enough seats they are justly
um incensed and indignant because they
know that they have been betrayed by the
people they pay to have their backs do
you think that the Republican Party
should split in half or split apart I
think the country should split in half
um I'm very much in favor of a national
divorce the Republican party is uh is is
an entity that survives despite failing
to understand how to talk like human
beings how to talk to human beings and
how to reflect the concerns of the
voters who out of you know the out of
the indefatigability of the human Spirit
keep hoping for the best and vote for
them anyway
um the party is not fit for purpose and
if it doesn't reinvent itself in Trump's
image um it doesn't deserve to live
Trump or Ron DeSantis that's going to be
the big debate here as well I don't
think anybody
um is seriously in favor of DeSantis
unless they're paid to be
I I strongly disagree with you on that
but but it's gonna be a topic
on Mega on the wrong side
Megan McCain's side at all uh but but
more importantly here there is something
to say about this performance in the
face of economic inflation lockdowns
crime waves which seems like it wasn't
really affecting the election results
there's also the fact that a lot of
trump endorsed candidates didn't win
Trump's attacking some of them right now
and and the ones that he did and then
the ones he attacked one like here are
some examples of that the problem I I
felt a bit um uh icky seeing Trump whine
about the Consultants it didn't seem
like a kind of Alpha Dog daddy thing
that we're used to from Trump seemed to
um a little bit pathetic and my hope is
that he will announce soon and get his
mojo back because
um at the same time as he's taking these
very light touch teasing pot shots at um
DeSantis who has zero chance of uh
succeeding um look DeSantis is almost as
popular as Trump in some bits of Florida
but don't ask them to choose because he
is gone the second they have to choose
between him and Trump don't don't get it
twisted okay
um he has no chance it is not happening
do you think even maybe in Tampa Trump
well Trump wasn't able to flip those
districts you're out of your mind if you
think that
um somebody with the Charisma of a
potted Cactus
um can go up against Donald Trump and
not end as just another casualty on the
list
uh you're out of your mind and looking
at the
Rogues gallery of people who are being
paid to support DeSantis I think unless
you can provide a compelling case which
today I have not heard
um you are being charmingly naive in
falling in line with the worst people I
can give a very worse people in this
country uh
the worst people in this country who
want more than anything for the will of
the people to be subverted they want to
suffocate Trump and all he stands for
and he is of course merely a proxy he's
a he's um he's a shorthand for a variety
of things that they hate about Americans
they hate the ghostness of of of of of
the South they hate everything about
themselves they hate um Appalachia you
know with its lack of sophistication
they despise whether and are
contemptuous of the people who love
Trump and they are The Architects of
their misery I mean there's a reason
that the the the these places that vote
for Trump have drug problems it's
because the coastal Elites
systematically killed these towns by
taking all the manufacturing abroad to
weaken the economic uh um clout of place
of Republican places okay these places
were deliberately and systematically
sabotaged and the result of that is like
human misery on a scale that nobody
really truly comprehends there's now no
reason for many of these towns in the
South to exist and they stagger on with
no factories with no jobs with no hope
and people lose themselves in
godlessness and in drugs and in um uh
all manner of of
um of self-destructive uh behaviors
that was done to them that was done that
was the thing that was done to them okay
uh and Trump is is a is a a neat
shorthand for the kinds of people that
Coastal Elites are considered to be
beneath them and the the DeSantis
project is about ensuring that Trump was
a
temporary unfortunate blip never to be
repeated because they think they have
the right to determine that they think
they have the right to dictate that
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time